那我要是你的话，
我怎么可能把这20万给我妈妈呢？
我不可能的，
我有时候想想啊，
他给我养到初中，
我初中才多大，
15岁是吧？
我这15年我能吃多少饭，
我这15年我能穿几件衣服，
上来就问我要20万的彩礼，
那我不能够，
我不给03年的目前工作收入是1万多，
自己存款全有50万左右，
自己名下有一台全款的一辆车，
大概30万左右，
现在我是跟我99年的那个男朋友在谈一块，
目前有想结婚的那个打算，
她现在目前在考公，
她现在在老家，
我现在在广东，
她是有意愿，
就是说考来我这边工作的，
我妈妈她是讲彩礼，
她是一分不给我，
但是我不太想给他结婚这方面，
我姐姐就劝我，
让我给我妈算了，
不要计较这个养育之恩了，
现在就有点纠结，
因为我妈不会给我陪嫁，
也不会给我任何钱，
就以后结了婚都得靠自己，
我现在就有点纠结，
这个钱我是怎么搞也不给他，
就那个彩礼，
彩礼是多少钱？
彩礼我是打算要20万左右，
你妈妈还要求你给他多少，
房东买房你妈妈要求给多少，
我妈想要26万左右，
但是我不太想要那么多，
就是假设要了20万，
这20万你妈妈是全要是吗？
对她说一分不给我，
你还有几个？
兄弟子妹呀，
我大姐带有一个弟弟哦，
那你妈妈有重男轻女吗？
有一点点读到哪个学历呀？
我读了初中我就出来上班了，
初中就出来上班了，
你自己名下现在这些财产有没有你妈妈给你置办的呀？
没有，
全都是了自己在的，
也就是说你读到初中就自己养活自己了，
你妈妈在你身上的投资就是把你喂饱了，
从小学到初中，
供你吃，
供你穿，
给你喂饱是这个意服，
对吧？
对，
那我要是你的话，
我怎么可能把这20万给我妈妈呢？
我不可能的，
我有时候想想啊，
他给我养到初中，
我初中才多大，
15岁是吧？
我这15年我能吃多少饭？
我这15年我能穿几件衣服？
上来就问我要20万的彩礼，
那我不能够，
我不给，
因为我不是婚内，
有50万的存款吗？
我有45万做了定期，
留了五六万，
十万左右应该是做了活期，
就是我结婚的话，
我是在想我那个彩礼到时候我可以拿到自己手上，
到时候结婚给我男朋友买房，
我是直接拿着20万出来买房，
自己再拿20万出来装修，
因为我两家一起嘛，
我跟我男朋友，
因为我妈也不会出什么钱给我买房子，
总共要花多少钱呀，
包括装修，
可能在广东首付应该付个二三十个，
装修可能要拿个15万出来，
因为我如果给。
还里给我妈，
我男朋友那边肯定是没有太多钱，
是给首付给那些的，
因为我想拿过来给我自己，
到时候我自己定划得用，
男方那边现在是没有房子是吧，
我对象他老家有，
其实我在广东没有，
他要要过来跟我生活，
那我肯定要在广东买房的，
其实我觉得你这个年纪哦，
23岁的年纪，
可以不着急买房子，
先租房子结婚啊，
为什么呢啊，
现在的离婚率摆在这里，
我怕你哦，
两家人凑钱买了房子了之后，
到时候又是经济纠纷，
麻烦的很，
你先租房，
两个人住在一起，
先感受一下性格呀，
生活习惯呀，
各方面合不合适再考虑结婚，
结婚也可以租房子先租个两年看一看，
为什么啊，
基本上离婚这个事儿的话，
在女性怀孕生孩子这个阶段是最容易发生矛盾的，
等到有了孩子之后，
将来比如说孩子要上学了，
在哪上学再考虑在哪儿买房子都来得及，
这过来人的感觉啊，
那会儿两口子感情都挺稳定了是吧，
也度过了那个特别容易焦虑，
特别容易发脾气，
特别两口子矛盾特别深的那个时刻了，
对未来的规划更清晰，
孩子将来想在哪上学呀，
想在哪读幼儿园啊，
就在哪附近再买个房都行。
完了之后你呢，
比如说你的前面的50万存款，
包括你要是能拿到手，
能拿到20万的彩礼的话。
这些钱你分开存，
你自己的存款，
你单独存在一张，
比如说建行卡里面，
以后就不要动，
然后这20万的彩礼钱你就存在农行卡里面不要动，
然后你平时的工资卡，
平时的生活消费，
比如说招商银行，
你就用这张就完事儿了，
这样就可以保证说能区分的开哪张卡里的是我婚前的存款，
哪张卡里的是彩礼钱，
万一将来一年两年，
万一出现什么矛盾的话，
那我的彩礼钱和我的婚前的存款没有混在一块儿，
是不是啊，
他就是一先不要买房，
我家里的关系我不知道怎么处理，
我妈妈我真的不知道怎么说他这种观念，
他这种观念非常的自私，
他说不给他就要断绝关系，
那你觉得是你害怕断绝关系呢，
还是他害怕断绝关系呢？
断绝关系对于你有什么坏处呢？
没什么坏处，
但是两个什么不好一点，
对呀，
你怕什么呢？
行，
谢谢，
好，
就这样啊，
刚刚我也看到有人评价他说，
哎，
是他自己不愿意读书呢，
他自己读不进去呢，
我始终觉得啊，
如果我有个闺女，
就算他不愿意读书，
那我也不舍得他15岁就出来谋生，
就出来打工，
就出来挣钱，
就出来受这个委屈，
我不知道你们是什么心情，
当你们听到一个女儿15岁自己就出来挣钱了，
现在她23岁，
人家都已经攒下来四五十万的存。
换了我，
不知道你们是什么心情对不对？
你不管怎么说，
这个妈妈对他的女儿，
你说有几分是爱，
有几分是心疼，
有几分是利用，
有几分是想着我拿这20万，
我得给我儿子当彩礼钱，
给我儿子好好的读书，
有几分是这种算计，
你们自己心里不清楚吗？
记得点赞关注哦。